Hi my name is Mimi Onuoha.
I'm an artist and researcher.
I'm based in Brooklyn.
Most of my work has to do with missing data,
and the data that goes into these algorithmic
and artificial intelligence systems.
I think if we ever want artificial intelligence
to go down a more inclusive path then we have
to make sure the public is more involved in
decisions and conversations that we have about
it.
And so a lot of the art that I create is about
translating these concepts into things that
the public can respond to.
For example, one of the main projects I work
on is around missing datasets.
And it's about all of the data that isn't
being collected.
And so what I do is I look at the patterns
behind why certain things aren't collected
and talk about what it means that we live
in a society where the systems that we're
creating are based on data, but we can't ever
collect everything that we need.
I think that the only way that we can engage
more people is if we focus equally on translating
and communicating these issues — put as
much focus on that as we put on actually talking
about them within our more academic, legal,
policy based communities.
I think art is important because it has the
ability to change the narrative and shift
the framework of the way that we actually
think about these things.
It allows us to imagine different possibilities
and different futures for how we can be using
these technologies, instead of getting caught
up in this trap of constantly responding to
the harms that we see.
Going forward we need more funding for artists
and other people who are doing this kind of
work.
Especially, there are a lot of creative people
who are working with code and working with
machine learning, and know the language and
know the tools, but there's not very much
incentive for them to stay and create this
kind of work, and instead there's so much
more incentive for them to go into working
for these corporations and actually helping
reinforce the systems that we might be against.
So I think we need more funding, we need more
incentives for people to keep on creating
this sort of work.